on this episode a man I respect dearly
comes here with his tremendous book
Scott Belsky is in the house I think
you're gonna love today's episode hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is the askgaryvee show episode 2 9
0 290 and where we've really gotten what
the askgaryvee show at this point is
special guests people that I'm
interested in friends or curiosities and
this one will go into friends deep
friends actually one of my favorite
buddies from the tech world over the
last decade a lot of you who follow me
always love to bring up the the jam
sessions after Chris Sacca exposed it in
some sort of Vanity Fair article or
something because and it's been made out
to be way more than it is it's not as
secret societies I think some people
like to think it's super not glamorous
Scott and I many of our buddies at South
by Southwest would cram into a hotel
room and bathroom who's in that bath
that year who is it with actually
sitting in the bath maybe I think it was
the co-founder of producthunt Eric right
Faris wasn't in the bath you know what I
remember about that one
Daymond John came do you remember and it
was like you just sit the [ __ ] is it in
the doorway actually that's exactly
right and he and we became friends later
and he was like what was that I was like
dude that was like I was like dude it's
honestly you know exactly what it is
it's funny I was walking watching a
documentary of Steven Spielberg and they
showed that those directors in the 70s
him George Lucas Spielberg Martin
Scorsese they just had a crew mhm and
there was like footage from it and what
were they doing they were cooking in a
shitty [ __ ] house sitting down and
talking right what was it it's we sat
there and we would say things like
snapchat go yeah Bitcoin go remember all
those things I remember and I also
remember Gary's rules so Gary would
enforce
you know a singular rule which is one
conversation at a time because you have
a lot of people people get carried away
side conversations happen you don't want
to miss anything so occasionally Gary
would be like whoa the rule guys one
conversation it was good it was great
and and it has something to add so it's
always interesting and one quick thing
cuz I'm gonna we're here to talk about
your book which I'm super excited about
and vaynernation let me say this you've
been following me for a while you might
have started follow me yesterday if
you've been following me for a long time
you know a couple of nuances about me I
it's not that I don't I respect everyone
but um but you know cuz I don't think
respect is like I'm like I give respect
then you could lose it you know my dad
was like respect is earned thus no one
has it but there are people that you
cross paths with in your career that
play in a different way and for a couple
reasons first as a human because I've
got a gnome friendly and family stuff
I'm just a very big fan of who you are
as a person but but subtly more on like
on the playing field Scott has had one
of the more remarkable angel and he
knows this I'm a real cheerleader for
him because and we brought him up renie
Saco and and crushed it I did solid but
you really destroyed it like destroyed
it not to make you bashful and I won't
even go into because I want to go into
the book but but whether it's Pinterest
or uber or you know periscope like I
have emails that are just legend their
legendary from Scott of like hey you
should meet the periscope founders or
the time where I was pretty early on my
belief in Pinterest in the macro and
Scott was trying to help me get in cuz
he had already been in an uber where a
lot of you know I famously
talk about how many times I passed on it
when Travis and I were homie homies like
so you've you were you had a remarkable
run as an angel and also was a founder
of a company that had a tremendous exit
and he executed it over longevity and it
wasn't a VC financial arbitrage thing
and just I'm just unbelievable I know
walk to me
and by the way I I can understand that
but but but they're not right like you
like you unlike me went to a good school
you think and you and you could have
gone down the path of the cliche thing
how old are you 38 right that's the
other thing there's a lot going well
Scott but like you you you know I know
enough about you and I'm speeding up
here a little bit you went down a path
that could have gone down a more
conservative path you could say lucky I
could say you saw what the internet was
you put yourself in it which then
created the serendipity of those
relationships because you could have
been on Wall Street you could have been
a doctor you could have been like you
could have been a consultant you could
have done a lot of other things that a
lot of people of our age group did you
didn't
thus I don't know I'm always wrestling
with two things one which is everyone
says focus on one thing do it well say
no to everything and a lot of people I
respect are really good at saying no to
things and staying focused yes and then
I wrestle with that versus following
every fascination yes and a lot of the
things you just mentioned were basically
fascinations that in some ways took me
off of what I was supposed to be doing
yes you know some might say Scott you
were bootstrapping a startup what the
hell are you doing spending time with
like Ben Silbermann interest helping
them think through a product and yes
raise you know what a five million
dollar valuation I was I try to
genuinely pursue fascinations yes and
then I try to for good or for bad
rationalize why I should be spending
timeless I mean it is slightly off my
path and I'm always trying to figure out
how it will contribute whether it works
out or not to like learning something I
will tell you that I've become so good
at that rationalization game like I'm in
the yes business I'm always doing all
sorts of ridiculous [ __ ] actually I said
I conference room with a big yes is that
what it means yeah yeah I mean like I
just think yes is powerful you know an
improv never say no I always say yes and
roll with it and to me the know players
of our friends were like focus focus
focus they're like look look how
successful I was I focus on my cool I
said yes and was helter skelter I'm
successful yeah like I think a lot of
this comes down to self-awareness yeah
you know I think when you can accept
yourself you know and for me you said a
very subtle thing in there that once you
learned that you have to accept it as a
net game yeah that those you know for
Ben's meeting that led to amazing things
with Pinterest
there was six others that led to nothing
absolutely or a waste of time or an
awkward situation or things that you
didn't want to deal with you know just
it's part of the game it is part of the
game and I mean one of my favorite words
is the word parlay you know just like
everything that you're doing parlaying
it or some aspect of it into something
else
everything is building upon itself but
sometimes something that I do that
totally fails only five or six years
later do I realize oh like there's
actually something I learned from that
that made me say yes to something else
or no difference or no or I will tell
you you know it's funny you said like
the reason I jumped in there was like
you know a lot of my mistakes helped me
get better at the nose in a world where
I want to say yes to everything
yeah so let's take a step back as I
jumped because I love you and I know you
so well for the people who are watching
listening who are you how do you think
about your comic book number one what is
your origin story born where - whoo Wow
give me like the three four minutes who
are you who am I gosh I mean you know I
start I was I grew up in Newton
Massachusetts my mother home of Mount
Ida College which no longer exists but
right and fun fact I don't know went out
of business the collar sold it was a
horrible College academically to begin
with now it's out of business and today
this morning walking out of my gym
another personal trainer bringing
somebody to lives in my home looks at me
he goes you look familiar
I go no yeah I'm Gary Vee he goes did
you go to Maui college this has only
happened twice twice only twice in the
last 20 years of my life the other time
quick fun fact Tollbooth in New Jersey
I'm getting pre EZ Pass I'm old giving
my quarters the guy goes Gary I like
Quincy it was amazing anyway nonetheless
yes Newton Mass so very nice town Newton
always makes me think of Short Hills
where Wine Library is so nice little
town by the way one of my earliest
memories is maybe six seven eight years
old I learned that there was like
colleges where you could have two year
programs programs yes and then there
were like universities we got graduate
degrees I remember you learning that and
be like I would never want to go to
university that's way too much school
like I want to do the two-year thing
that was actually really his memory is
it related Mount Ida but anyways so I
I grew up there and father orthopedic
surgeon and I would say like my work
ethic he every night
he would be doing dictation at night
where he would like be you know
recounting the surgery and whatever and
the lessons learned and in the morning I
remember him always like coming in my
room the morning be like come on school
you gotta get up you gotta go in school
you got it and so there's my energy high
energy and like and always about just
kind of like doing your thing like let's
sit down and do it together
like I just I think the work ethic I
know you feel similarly and I just
mentioned it because he's someone who
and as a doctor he just bedside manner
like the way he is with people and
patients and whenever I go home and you
know walk around with him he meets
people who took he took care of the
mother or the sister and he always
remember him and just something about
that always sticks with me but anyways I
grew up there always was had an
entrepreneurial instinct to me I'm
convinced that I invented e-zpass
because I had a I had a I always made
stores in the home and then I actually
made a toll booth for the stairwell so
like and I was like I'll keep the
stairwell clean I'll vacuum it and
people will just give me a toll when
they go up and down and then I realized
that was a lot of work so I gave people
passes they could just go without having
to pay and that was way before EZ Pass
anyways it was it was a my whole family
was very patronizing of my my early
entrepreneurial ventures but um high
school started a little kind of apparel
company called live big my friend's
initials were bi G so we like may live
big and then it became nothing but we
owned live big comm and then sophomore
year of college I get an email and when
did you only big comm back in like 1996
and then college when I registered
winelibrary.com right around cycle 19
you know it's really interesting about
this this is kind of super weird you you
were in high school you said yeah in
Newton yeah that probably means that you
and I both registered
in 1996 live big calm and
winelibrary.com
in Newton Mass wild I like that that
makes me happy you know and registry was
like what's all this activity
try to think about which what was it was
their network solutions never solutions
that's why yeah that's how you did -
yeah
the recall 100% know how they gone back
there was no gold yeah this guy's pre
GoDaddy no it was a it was a pain in the
ass - yeah there was you have the facts
something there is probably a fax with a
signature and uh-huh and everything on
it took wild a problem you youngsters
have no [ __ ] idea this is our version
of we walked in the snow we in a fax to
get our websites kids keep knowing
anyways this became nothing however saw
from your college you get an email from
a RV company you know those big things
that you've risen right yes and then
they're like what do you think I'm like
some trillionaire in a [ __ ] ivory
tower I don't know [ __ ] our nation's
go ahead big live living something big
and you were like we want to buy live
big and I was like well it's not just a
job it's a 10-bit company and so I think
I negotiated a $7000 acquisition you
know my first company pretty sight
because I was like sophomore year
college I just you know my company got
acquired and they you know from that Ben
was at Princeton and it was just one of
those moments where we were like alright
were you literally walking around campus
like yo baby my company just was applied
kind of a big yeah okay but it was it
was a first for a hey even if it was a
very small and micro journey it was a
journey nonetheless they gave you a high
of what like did you get a high on the
holy [ __ ] soon I I definitely got some
sort of high yeah that it was I mean
wasn't going anywhere but it was a it
was a it was a taste of coming up with
something that babies want to get into
domain naming for a second I always that
would have tricked me I would be like
yeah you know I whenever I had an idea
I'm sure yeah me too but I wasn't lying
domains like a real estate portfolio
I'll never forget that business 2.0
magazine that had the cover and it said
fish dot-com 130 million I don't
remember the second episode about the
crazy nature of the domain industry and
who the holders are of all these domains
as you know they're these brokers that
go around with like cases of cash trying
to buy these things for people as well
but um it's actually amazing that it's
still around but on real estate it is
real estate fast forward
graduated college
always had an interest in design and
business in college I studied both
design and business had to choose one
ended up choosing Wall Street for a few
years you know how to one-and-a-half
years on a traditional finance job hated
it and went to my manager and was like
I'm gonna leave and she was like well
there's one thing you could do in this
firm like what would it be I was like
I'm really interested in understanding
like how leaders make decisions and how
a firm is managed and how problems are
solved and so I got this crazy job at
Goldman Sachs in the executive office
focusing on almost like internal
management consulting when co-heads
don't get along when clients are going
through struggles but they don't want to
tell anyone else but they like confide
in the firm and have their help and that
experience actually was a great
education for me interesting yeah that
was three years Wow
yeah it was a great experience and and I
still like actually pull from it which i
think is rare usually out of college you
have [ __ ] jobs or you don't actually
refer to anything but fast forward I
left and started behance the idea of
Behance organized the creative world I
used to tell people that and they're
like yeah you know good luck with that
but it he has long story short became a
network of over 15 million creatives
showcasing their work getting
attribution for the work that they did
agencies typically take all the credit
usually it's the creatives at the end of
the day that actually did a lot of this
stuff and now they get opportunity we're
acquired by Adobe in 2012
how long have you run that company so
this was a it was five years of
bootstrapping which we could talk about
forever that was rough
two years as a venture-backed company so
Union Square Ventures Jeff Bezos Chris
Dixon a bunch of other Angels back in
the day that was probably one of the
other emails like I lost in your inbox
that was before you know I don't know
about that what you're just kidding and
just get 2007 yeah I don't think was
2000 I trade wine for probably would
have helped us anyways so um so yeah I
think that it was that was an incredible
journey and you know one of the
inspirations for the messy metal was me
actually thinking back to that five year
period of bootstrapping and tears as
venture-backed company during 2008
folders mm - so no sorry so the company
started in 2005 5
sex right around there and then we we
actually raised the real round in 2000
and late 2010 2011 you got a little
angel money in seven from yes from
friends and family that make sense and
but like barely any and then and you
sold to Adobe one in 2012 late end of
2012 yeah so as a as quite a journey and
you know actually didn't when I was
sitting down to think about this book
which is really the aggregation of like
five to seven years of little insights
around people's middles friends of mine
entrepreneurs artists writers who
endured and optimized through a very
volatile middle journey I was like well
I got to start with my own and I realize
I didn't remember it and actually what I
did is I went back in my phone through
all the screenshots from like the years
2006 to 2012 just was like that's the
probably the source of truth for where I
was what I was thinking and what I was
doing and I saw all the like you know
screenshots of people giving us a hard
time online or people liking what we
were doing online or errors or issues
and team moments and tough moments and
celebrations and all that stuff and
actually that was the first moment I got
the granularity of some of the stuff
frankly that I had wanted to forget you
know no I think it's a really
interesting thesis I think that in
general if you even think about like a
movie people can think about like the
beginnings of movies and how it ended
like the middle is a very fascinating
part of everything when you look at it
in its entirety a lot of times you don't
know you're in the middle it's funny
you're talking like I'm in the middle of
the whole Baner X thing right now yeah
right like this is the mockery like like
you know like the me and AJ part you
know a new new agent where like that was
fun and did it and like boy do I think
it's going to be a monster and so
there'll be that part but I'm squarely
in the [ __ ] middle right now I think
that well first of all hopefully we're
always in the middle to some extent
where we do it but um I think it's also
fascinating that yes there's all this
volatility there's surfing endless
ambiguity working in anonymity no one no
one cares what you're doing which
actually sometimes a good thing as well
as a bad thing whatever you would
actually argue this is a really
interesting thought I know that you know
since we've been in so many jams
together I know
a tangent here I actually think that
that's exactly right and as a strength
and I actually think that a lot of kids
right now and and not just kids are
actually doing too much content creation
and self-promotion mm-hmm
which is a vulnerability when you're in
that middle meaning I posted the other
day like under being underestimated is
the great gift yeah and everybody spends
all their time trying to prove
especially you know think about the time
look at the youngsters you're 22 to 23
now everything is like trying to prove
to your parents and your contemporaries
that you're good and you start doing a
ton of [ __ ] to me that's such an
interesting point when you're in the
messy middle yeah I I think being head
down not being out there and not hearing
other voices because that is your most
vulnerable time hundred percent it's a
strength yet so many people are trying
to put their lives out there yeah that
they're getting a lot of signals and I
think it's not a you know I think in the
beginning and the end there's a little
bit more it's a very interesting point I
mean I think I talked about a you know
the the fact that we're all governed by
the short term reward system and from
from from birth right it's like we're
constantly getting our parents
gratification then the check on the test
and the grade in the course and then you
know Fred Wilson at one of our Fred
Wilson ventricles in New York out of one
of our early conferences that you're the
two greatest addictions in life are
heroin and a weekly salary and like
talking about like unplugging yourself
from that and and and what the
implications are of that and I think
that a lot of in during the middle
journey is about like hacking your
reward system but to your point you
don't want to you don't want to have
like fake wins that are motivating you
you don't want to put out content and
feel like that means I'm winning
actually you want to build something
that's lasting and real and actually I
feel like the best company is launched
without press they actually get
something out there and validate it and
get something it's working so well and I
feel like press is relative to what it's
announced not what had happened Scott do
you know I hate that I'm at a point in
my career that anything I start now
comes with expectation mmm-hmm like like
it's one of the you know this is so full
circle because we were talking before it
stops you from experimenting well it's
weird I feel like this whole sports card
thing is kind of like like I'm sitting
here like oh [ __ ] I'm probably doing
this sports card thing because yes it's
out there but nobody's gonna
get seriously thus I like it like I
literally have like this interesting
like one of the reasons I think that
I've been able to navigate is I hate
short-term success yeah I was pumped
with bad grades yeah I love being
underestimated I loved being the wine
guy in the tech world you know I loved
being the wine guy in the ad world like
I like I literally I'm starting to like
think like like it's why I'm loving my
global expansion yeah I love that nobody
knows who the [ __ ] I am in Singapore at
first or India or you know like and also
I love how you do the yardsale stuff
because it's sort of like hey everyone's
talking about big deals I'm just trying
to flip this thing from five bucks to
seven bucks you know you said like the
hot first of all the high of finding a
stuffed animal for 30 cents that sells
for 27 bucks and the other thing is look
I'm a little bit like connect with your
dad like I want to walk down the street
with my son one day and somebody come up
to me be like hey and look at my son and
be like hey your dad changed the course
of my life yeah that's that's a big ROI
and so the whole yard sale thing here 90
[ __ ] eight percent of the people
watching my content would die out of
happiness to make a thousand dollars
extra a week right and I know exactly
how they can do it yeah in a way that's
so scary like retail arbitrage right now
now let's jump detect
dude you can't imagine the ARB yeah you
just sat at a desk with a computer and
bought on eBay Etsy Amazon just traded
Craigslist Facebook marketplace if you
just bought and sold sold bought and
sold including buying case up buying
inventory on eBay and shipping it to
Amazon you can make so much money
Gary yeah I mean I read actually an
interesting debate we had at a jam
session a few years ago which was is it
easier or harder to make a dollar in the
modern day mmm and sure was Mark Cuban
or someone else there it was like it's
harder I actually feel like it's
certainly certainly easier I'm not
saying that it's easier to make a lot
maybe there's a there's a sort of a
larger commoditization of labor going on
and that's obviously an issue but I
really do think that there are so many
avenues for people just to connect the
dots and it's accessible to so many
internet is grossly underestimated
yeah it's grossly underestimated the
longtail yeah I just I don't notice to
say I also think that people I think
that it's not just about where things
are distributed or purchasable it's also
about like the curation that happens in
between and how its presented and how
its merchandise so you can find
something that's merchandize in a shitty
way and you can actually turn it around
and present it properly containers and
merchandising even if it's a better
freaking foe containers and I mean I
don't even want to get into this I'm so
into this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah containers
and merchandising yeah I'll get into
that later yeah messy middle yes who's
listening in a matrix of like who's the
who's the ultimate person yeah
100% should buy this who's the neck I
like to think of books in three tiers of
like a triangle
yeah like the top of the triangles like
you this will change your game like is
it made for you then there's the big
middle of that of like this is probably
probably for you and then like the
curious kind of new water but so break
that down for me one two and three who
was like listening and watching right
now absolutely yeah this I think that
the more involved this is get to it yeah
we get that a minute but the real quick
it's a good question I think that the
well the more volatile the more this
book is for you I really do believe that
there are every time yeah essentially
everything that everyone's doing is
either a venture or a replay a venture
in the sense that it's going into
unknown territory whether you're in a
big company doing a product turn around
and doing something that's off the radar
and you're fighting the immune system of
the big company or if you're just an
entrepreneur starting something up and
hustling you know if you are venturing
this is for you if you're doing the
replay playing someone else's playbook
probably not as relevant I also would
say that in the volatility side of
things the point of this book right is
that we are not our best self at the
lowest of the lows nor the highest of
the highs yes the lowest of the lows
we're making decisions out of fear
we're losing hope we're trying to manage
uncertainty and ambiguity you know we're
realizing we have to short-circuit our
reward system there's a ton in here
about like enduring the lows mining them
for the gems you know and building the
muscle memory to to to endure future
lows and making every low incremental e
higher right yes and then on the highs
the thing about the peaks is that
we start to actually falsely attribute
the things that we did right - - to us
peeking and so a lot of this also is
about looking at anything that works and
then working like hell to optimize it
and it's ironic that in the messy middle
when things work we typically don't do
anything with it because we've got
enough [ __ ] to deal with right but when
actually something is working whether
it's how you're managing your team how
you're hiring how you're managing
yourself or something that's in your
product that actually is getting a
little traction on the contrary we
should be iterating around that right
and so this is a lot about optimizing
the things that work across team product
and self like how you're kind of
managing your own show then there's a
final section at the end called the
final mile and this is a collection of
insights around why so many people screw
things up in the final mile of a project
there is the turnaround we're about to
launch we don't mess this up there's the
self sabotage that happens after you're
about to launch something to the world
the questions of do I even deserve this
and the subconsciously what that does to
you and your team I share some stories
and they're about that stick on this
yeah I mean on the self sabotage front I
talk about an example of somebody on my
team who really in the final mile of
behance when we were already in talks
for acquisition and everything else just
started to do a lot of kind of
inappropriate stuff right and you know
first I was like come on man you know
like that's not good I probably
shouldn't say that people you probably
shouldn't be doing that you know with
these team members in the weekend and
whatever else and and but it just kind
of escalated and and I really started to
get very worried about it and people
were coming to me about it I was really
getting curious and I remember going
home one night to my wife Erica who you
know there's a psychologist I'm kind of
talking about it and she was just like
oh like this is easy like he doesn't
feel like he deserves it I'm like what
do you mean like we're all about to
succeed this is gonna be a great outcome
for him he's like no he just he's not
comfortable with it and first I was like
I don't know I mean and then I so then
the next day end of the day other real
quick everybody this is my favorite part
about life you know she's a psychologist
you're like doing this thing you come
home she gives you the answer he's like
nah like I like I'm buddies like
literally this has happened to me so do
I apologize for jumping in because
clearly I'm doing a better job than
normal listening and as to why I love
Scott but last week I've had so many
people literally on the street grab me
and be like
you say this my homie Jerome says this
I'm like well what's Jerome up - well he
sucks I'm like well don't you think it's
a good idea to think about who's giving
the advice not all advice is equal I
just love that you come home you respect
your work tremendously I know that for a
fact
she's a seg hunch she tells you oh this
is easy she listen how he said it
oh this is easy he's not okay with it
you're like nah it doesn't make
intuitive sense right to me and but yeah
I think that the point is that the final
mile it's a different playbook
altogether able to put them aside sit
down with him in the corner of a
conference room where no one could see
ya know and I didn't go down the right
of the path of like you deserve this -
bro so actually that's exactly what I
did yeah you know I said to him like
this is a problem like but here's the
thing like forgetting all that I want to
tell you something I looked it in the
eye and I was like you deserve this love
like we could work together for years
and you serve this at first he was like
what are you talking about
and I actually repeated myself two more
times and he started to cry that's
amazing and and listen like I don't know
what exactly happened in that moment
yeah but I know that we embrace at the
end of it yeah and I know that things
changed that's amazing and I think he
just needed I needed to have someone
kind of tell him yeah it's something
about it triggers and it just taught me
something about the fact that when
people go through big transitions
especially when your identity is so tied
up in something that you're building and
then something changes towards the final
mile it is really different you need
different advisors you need different
you didn't need a different playbook and
that's what it's about
I love that do you feel that um has
anybody who's had an early I know this
is just coming out is this is it out
words are coming out next Tuesday West
middle pre-orders just started it's it's
coming out in 20 days science is hitting
October so you're being smart and trying
to drive sales now I am trying to learn
from the best so listen I mean this
there are very few people that I would
cosign this heavy where I'm going very
interesting with this is I have a funny
feeling and listen the problem Scott is
he's smart so I'm worried that the book
might be too smart for me but I actually
think there's a lot of nuances here
about parenting hmm so you're talking
I'm like this is [ __ ] parenting this
is [ __ ] parenting this is [ __ ]
parenting I'm curious just to see I'm
curious to think the people at
there that are both passionate about
their careers and businesses but also
about being parents I have a funny
intuitive feeling and I'm dying to see
in four months when I stumble back to
this or the comments or somebody tweets
me and says that was a right cut I'm so
intuitively curious it's so funny you
say this because two things one is
someone the other day who read it an
early galley said to me you could
written you could substitute every like
business word in there for relationship
and it would be true and then yesterday
I kid you not I'm talking to somebody
who's starting a wild company in the
fishing industry which I'm happy to tell
you that offline but what he what it
what he's my lesson carries what he said
to me is like I have to tell you the
messy middle perfectly applies to
fishing expeditions I'm like what are
you talking about my father is a
commercial fisherman and he always says
like you know there's very great
volatility from the start to the end of
an you know a fishing expedition the
last two weeks deep-sea fishing it's
like the messy middle perfectly applies
I'm like really I did not anticipate
because of the jet streams when on
Monday when you first said I'm like okay
this is the second and third quarter
this is perfect for football I think
that situation what do you got okay
Michael
yeah well listen I think that um I think
that creative teams don't necessarily
like to subscribe all to the same system
right and I think that's one of the
reasons why so many these companies that
have built like productivity and project
management tools it's never been a
winner take all market because most we
people talk about switching costs like
investors like Gary and I will look and
say oh is there a high switching cost of
this product and will retain its people
the funny thing about the creative world
is actually switching benefits when a
creative team hoanib stops using a tool
it's almost like spring cleaning
everyone will start to engage and love
the new product which is why you go from
like Trello to clubhouse 2-0 to all
these different kind of methods and
systems so actually I think that for a
creative team you have to start paying
attention to the the elegance of the
system I mean think about it creatives
are we want different colored folders we
want to have something that we're
visually attracted to attraction breeds
loyalty over time and so if you're a
programmer
project manager of a creative team and
you're trying to manage the minutes with
a spreadsheet that will not work you got
to be a little more creative with it
the only thing I'll jump in here on is I
believe the advancement of technology a
lot of people talk about in the
advertising world personalization right
I see Jets ads you see like it gets that
good that we get there yeah I think
that's great and exciting fine I'm so
much more into that in management like I
genuinely think when I what the missus
in a million ways is we we make such
general statements about things the only
way to manage a team perfectly is to
manage them on an individual level on an
everyday basis and having a pulse of
their ambitions wants desires and needs
in an every second basis I'm not kidding
that is how you actually win it now how
you actually do that
yes right correct but I think you scale
it with [ __ ] people yeah like you
know give me a like like just speak more
often watch more of it the way I scale
it I follow my people on social mm-hmm
I'll give you an example I look at
review cycles here and I see people
reviewing each other I know that they're
hiking with each other on the weekend
which means that review is better than
it's supposed to be those [ __ ] or
homies it's context of course context is
the [ __ ] gateway to all of this yeah
and so you know to my two cents on this
is like look when I hear people say Gary
how do I manage my team of 30 I'm like
go to breakfast lunch and dinner make it
a family no [ __ ] yeah because things
change Seth today may want more money
but when he starts a family may want
more time yes right yeah somebody might
want more recognition today because
they're insecure or they want to
leverage it for another job later they
want more privacy and don't want it I
agree it's not a person-by-person basis
and that's a problem he managers feel
like they have to start scaling every
way that they manage as they grow and in
fact to your point it's really about it
and then and then our tools become
band-aids yes right ok it's absolutely
great
well lead
industries in terms digital marketing
strategy some industries still use
digital marketing in a very primitive
way while others are taking full
advantage and implementing solutions
through proven brand identity and
business decisions maybe business
decision making got it how can we go to
cease gas and further I mean you're the
expert I have thoughts but go ahead why
don't you go with your thoughts no I
mean I think that I think that well my
day job now which we didn't really talk
about that's what I think when you up to
now I came back and and jumped in as a
new chief a little bit what's that you
did BC for a little bit yeah yeah so the
ants acquired by Adobe three years had
the best time building products for
creative people yeah everyone kept
saying because of the seed investing
you've got to be an investor you got to
be an investor and actually made a
mistake which is I started to believe
everyone around me that and telling me
what I should be doing I mean it was
Gary's credit actually Gary you know
knew knew better than me at this point I
felt part of me felt like I had to try
it if everyone's telling me I should be
a venture investor I should just do it
full-time jumped in full-time three
weeks and I'm like I'm not building
products anymore I'm not working with
teams anymore I'm working on isolation
I'm trying to win the deal I'm playing
this transactional game I don't know if
this is me I don't know if I want to so
in the next 15 years of my life doing it
yet I was at the one of the best venture
capital firms in the world learning
enjoying every single day of absorbing
from the folks around the table at
benchmark and then I had this kind of
question about but can I do this or 15
years and be the best at this or should
I go back to building I'm just gonna
just get to the chase my level of
respect for Scott was already pretty
obnoxiously high in the scheme of things
because the serendipity of actually
spending some time because I'm sure
there's plenty of other people I'd love
to respect I just don't spend time with
people in the scheme of things and then
who we ended up being the fact I
couldn't over communicate enough to the
people watching listening the level of
the plum plum plum job in the game of
venture capital that Scott got to that
so I'm so weird that I don't know things
very well like you guys kind of know me
he gets it
fine I hear about it but other people
that I massively respect and think are
super smart and great we're like wow
I was like oh [ __ ] it must be really
really big to have the ability to land
that and then to have the self-awareness
and be willing to deal with the Scarlet
Letter that the micro community would
look and put on you when you left it
yeah like that's what it is dude for you
I can't this is a very big deal Scott
for you to get it and then leave it
fairly early very quickly in the scheme
of things yeah
which in a lot of ways could have been
viewed as disrespectful in a lot of
different ways especially in the micro
community of venture capital right to
have the internal strength to know oh
darn it this is not who I am and be able
to make that kind of move yeah is a much
bigger deal than I think people will
give you credit for it was it's hard to
distract yourself from something you
committed to I mean I knew it wasn't
right for me here whoever's knew it
wasn't right for me absolutely and and
also I want to do it I want to do in
good terms you know I'm still eventually
partner we have for him now and it was
important to me because I have so much
respect for the firm team but I also
knew that it wasn't good for 15 years I
felt like I'd hung a call you so what
did you do so I jumped out I was like
okay what do I want to do what am I most
happy doing honestly it's building
products for creative people it's what
I've always been doing even though I had
sold the company why do I have to stop
doing that so and also the best starting
a new company what did you think I
thought about a lot of these things I
realize that my perfect happy place was
building products for creative people
working with people that I love and
investing as something I do as the sort
of this I hustle if you will and so I
said well what's wrong with just going
back and doing then at the time
Shantanu the CEO of Adobe had come to me
and was like I'm thinking about this
chief product officer role it would you
consider coming back at first I'm like I
don't I don't know if I would ever come
back to a place I already left and
extracted myself from and whatever else
and then I realized if I feel like
there's a strategy that gets me excited
and I have the team and like the founder
DNA that I still have within the company
because it'd be Hans's acquisition so I
said why not let's jump in and so now
we're kind of thinking about the future
of the creative world as well as
thinking about this question around
digital mark
and creative tools and how is coming
together question bring it back to the
question I don't know where the energy
was for his question my answer is you
don't
so first of all there's industries but
there's no this back to managing people
ok cool like apparel companies have
figured it out
not all apparel companies like cement
companies have not figured it out well
there's some guy in Minnesota who's
killing it selling cement on Facebook I
think the answer is you don't
this is what I love about the game I as
a you know a Pied Piper actually don't
give a [ __ ] if anybody does anything
about it as a matter of fact i weirdly
prefer they don't because I so enjoy the
merit of doing right things and wrong
things I will tell you all the best
things and my best of ability but if you
don't act on them I can't wait to see
you in four years and be like I told you
and look you know this back to these jam
sessions there was no bigger advocate
for social for social for social in
those meetings in 9 and 10 and that all
of this was far less obvious than it
then today you know back then than it is
today
I think people always us underestimated
the communication tools and I think they
continued to never so at this point
everybody's so ready for AI and AR and
blockchain and so many other things four
or five social networks are literally
dictating the behavior of seven point
seven billion people yeah there's
munication communication yep anyway
let's get this call it ya know call from
Massachusetts soir geek my home state I
know we didn't get into the Patriots
thing you're not that big of a patch man
range that was sworn ich oh my god it's
Gary and Scott how are you I am
fantastic thank you so much for calling
me I love ya you show what you do
I'm Scott I think with you I mean you
are amazing Tiger pride I don't know if
you went to new North and doing South
but I was in Newton North I also grew up
in Newton did you go to processor I
would have gone to South I went to be a
knife
that question was asked I'm like this
guy with a [ __ ] private school I can
bet my house on it brother what's your
question so um I am I'm a male nurse and
I want to be the nurse guy just like you
were the wine guy interesting I think
it's very different and I think Scott
like how he rose the where he is today
is he went to school he learned at the
school way and you just did it like you
lived it right you just lived it I want
to know would you suggest I go to school
hardcore becomes a genius of Nursing and
then put out content or do my things
that way
or do I just I'm a nurse now but I'm
just like basic like just got into the
field nursing or should I just do
nursing and then like you know I know
exactly become I think we both
understand your question I'll let Scott
go first I mean I think the greatest
experience the greatest insights come
from experience not from school and I
mean personally I most I most enjoy
following and learning from people that
are having you know in tuition driven
experiences on the job in the experience
through the hardships of the day-to-day
and just how they curate and present and
analyze their own experiences as opposed
to someone who proclaims to be an expert
because of some degrees so I mean I'm
sure that school within the profession
of Nursing is extremely important but if
your question is around when do I start
sharing when do I start contributing
content you know and be and become being
part of the conversation and I'm sure
Gary would say start now well there's a
couple things couple things I want to
give Scott another compliment it was
funny when he was talking when we would
get in discussions in these jam sessions
about you know CTO structure you know
databases did it I would you know add my
two cents I can tell you that any time
we talked about Twitter or Facebook or
things that nature
I could feel Scott listening to me with
more respect than when we didn't and
that I always took note of that and when
he just gave that answer like that's
what was happening so that thing that's
interesting back to like listen to who's
who's giving the advice who's actually
living it because a lot of people
pontificated about social and they were
super smart people and VC's but they
weren't in it like I was in it number
two I think that here's how I think
about it the I got to I didn't
to go to school for it because buying
and selling stuff or running a liquor
store things that nature that didn't
necessarily come to school
I think sure you can start contributing
to the conversation today
I think my friend the mistake that
people make is they overstep their
boundaries of knowledge if you now
document your truth which is I'm a
youngster in the field I intuitively
feel that I have good bedside manners
but on the actual like tactician apart
of my job I'm still in the beginning of
my journey that's a very important know
what I would have done if this all
existed when I got into wine library
would I have fronted or would I have
been a little bit like my intuitions I
would have gone a little Mohammed Ali
with it which is like I'm 22 I'm in a
liquor store and I kind of go with the
content of like you'll say yeah yeah
I'll see you in 2015 yeah yeah right but
here's where I'm at now
um packing boxes at midnight because we
are getting more internet orders than I
expected that's cool actually
that's the coolest and that's kind of
where I'm going with this I think you
should contribute for a couple of weird
reasons number one in sixty years your
grandkids are gonna be really happy you
did so one of things I don't think
people understand about making content
is everyone's thinking short-term
selfish instant returns of how many
likes or will this get me something and
I'm saying the happiness that it's gonna
get you that you saw yourself when you
still had hair or black hair or young or
when you see your when your grandkid
comes up to you and goes grandma
granddad when you were 22 you were doing
this and I do that to so much in the
human race has been lost in history
outside of very famous people yeah now
we all have that one of the great
reasons I'm documenting everything is
that's how I'm actually gonna live
forever so I would document just for
life yeah where you could get caught and
where I see kids getting caught all day
is they're in there fronting they're
making pretend they're posturing this
they're faking it to you make it the
problem with faking it to you make it in
today's world is York's
Oh stranger so that's what I would say
yeah I mean yeah I just wanted that I
mean that deep the great I mean 60 years
from now as deep I do want to say I am
constantly putting content out there I'm
cute the nurses my thing um so I did
call you about a year ago and I was at
like 500 and people on Instagram I was
at zero people on YouTube I'm Way better
I mean the growth is slow I might like
3,000 on YouTube on my three four three
and a half thousand on Instagram and I
just want to thank you for that can I
jump in for a second yes and this is for
everybody [ __ ] everybody we have to
in our community stop
starting with vanity metrics like
followers because it's a terrible
framework to play with in that almost
always will eliminate the upside that
you actually possess I know it's a data
point and I'm not saying you're caught
up in it I'm using in I'm using this
moment to actually help all of us it's
very important let me tell you why it's
far less about having 3000 or 500 or 4.1
million followers it's more about a
single piece of content even when you
have nine followers or nine million
followers gives you the opportunity to
impact or create or selfishly creates
the step for what you're trying to
accomplish tomorrow you may make a piece
of content that serendipitously leads to
the head of a hospital in Austin Texas
to see it which miraculously in this
moment of time off the base of another
meeting leads to them reaching out to
you and changes your medical career that
is a very big deal I gave a speech at
the Javits Center in 2011 when nobody
really knew who I was I mean a little
something going on in Twitter but that
single piece of content still has had
bigger impact even though I have a much
bigger audience today you know I want to
make sure that people realize it's not
the size of the audience it's the
at-bats and the content that can lead to
things like impacting others or amazing
things for yourself and it's just a
framework we have to you know because
everybody's pandering to the numbers
people are not posting because they
don't get enough likes and they
overthink things
people are wrapping their self-esteem
into how many followers they have or or
checking their progression like what is
3000 from 500 mean that means up going
in the right direction what happens the
next time I talk to you in a year if
that 3000 is only 3,100 does that mean
you did worse maybe did better because
you're better at producing contextual
content so it's an important moment in
this conversation thank you and I just I
promise this the last thing and it's a
squat question for Scott and I know you
think we build products or creators and
I just have to ask because I've been
putting out all this content and I love
putting out the content I just I don't
know outside of the content and
monetization sometime in the future a
product that a nurse you know like it I
I do nursing news and I interview other
everyday heroes that are like nurses and
doctors and people like that I don't
know what a product I could use you know
base my creative on and if you have any
ideas that would be absolutely bedrock I
mean listen I'll give you a quick kind
of somewhat self-serving answer but also
something I believe in there's a product
called spark data that one of my team's
put out which is like a it's like a
social it's it's for social media
publishing it just helps you put like
videos with like the imagery together it
makes things basically look better with
less time and less talent behind them
frankly and just like you know putting
out but the point is is you do want to
experiment with the types of medium
media that you're creating obviously and
and I encourage you to add the add the
visual elements you know add the add the
sound elements and whatever else I think
that we all have to kind of have our own
little creative team even if it's within
us in order to put this stuff out there
and have it resonate though to say like
as you guys were talking I was recalling
the fact that my first ever blog was
called musings of a novice business mind
and it had to be anonymous because I was
working at Goldman at the time and we
weren't allowed to share anything online
but it was you know I don't even
remember what the hell I was writing but
it did create like a motion like a
motion of kind of taking something
putting it down thinking about it you
know and I I just for anyone who's
listening who is like oh you know
no if I have any content ready to share
yet I do think well it has to be true
and and just sharing you know whether
it's packing boxes and managing a big
day of orders that exceeded your
capacity or your your expectations or
whatever else there's something about
that like motion of writing [ __ ] down
that I think develops you people to
understand people people don't
understand that we have the advantage
from day one of being a human and having
our individual reality yeah and
everybody spends all their time trying
to take this unique flavor and turn it
into vanilla every I'm watching
everybody try to conform into what they
think works without realizing their
nuances is what works Scott I had people
reach out to me in our kind of circles
and tell me that what I'm doing with the
garage sale thing is a bad idea
in a loving way then I Gary you are like
it's so funny when being underestimated
it's a lot of fun having smart friends
you know I think there's something
unbelievably still respected about
universities and schools and me going to
Mount Ida versus Princeton there's an
underlining tone amongst my
contemporaries that there's still
certain things I don't get because we
grew up in a time where that had so much
value on intellect yet the games being
played out in such an emotional gray way
not that so I have friends so first of
all two things I love people reach out
to me like Gary you don't even know how
much you're impacting the world and I'm
like [ __ ]
I think I'm impacting the world more
than anybody I know
number two exactly thank you number two
a bunch of homies reached out and we're
like yo don't do this like that's what
you used to do like people you've got a
big audience now like there's you know
presidents and there's like real people
and they're like and if you do this it's
gonna make and I was like you are so
lost in the reality of how life works
I think it's wild that you know that the
the more your intuition works for you
the more people start to question the
volume of your own intuition
I'm sure you had a lot of feedback on
the decisions you made when you left
right and so for me they're like and not
listen I have more empathy that you know
if you're playing in that kind of cloud
that why is Gary buying stuffed animals
and posting it and like
could this hurt him it's coming from a
loving place but where I'm going with
this is the following because I'm a Jets
loving garage-sale loving rupee or
loving you know wine loving entrepreneur
de de de de these are the strengths not
the weaknesses and so where I'm going
with is if you're a young nurse and
you're trying to you know when you talk
about a product like spark not everybody
has a team producing our content so
you're gonna need to do different things
written word audio video but it all goes
to one place when you have inner
confidence like true self-esteem yeah
you will produce unlimited amounts of
content in all forms because you are no
longer crippled by the instant feedback
loop of likes and comments by the way
totally agree with that I always feel
like creative block is the consequence
of avoiding the truth period when you
pierce the truth period it flows period
let me give you an example real life we
are currently sitting here last night 11
p.m. I posted a video that was a minute
and 23 seconds long not made for
Instagram and I posted on Instagram cuz
I watched it and was ok with where it
ended at one minute knowing I was giving
up the punch that the 23 seconds had to
like really kill it which is why it will
do better on Twitter I post it at it not
a great time on Instagram but I wanted
to learn what it would do when I put a
piece of content that wasn't as native
as it could have been and not an optimal
time it did not well hmm which
reinforced my thesis of native content
and understanding it might have done
phenomenal like other times in the past
which reinforces [ __ ] break your own
[ __ ] rules ba ba ba here's the thing
if you don't have the confidence to go
there for example if I didn't have the
confidence to be okay with the fact that
my YouTube channel is not being
optimized at all over the last 15 months
hence why it's stale and if I my
identity was wrapped up into how many
subscribers or likes or comments well
then that's not what I would do at the
same token by not being crippled by that
it allowed me to follow the momentum to
create a top 100 podcast
people are just confused they look at
things in the micro and they don't macro
it up yeah and so when I hear a tool
when I hear his question what's the tool
that's gonna help me where it really
goes is first get into a place of
realizing that if you're comfortable
with everything yeah well then you can
do and when you do you will learn thank
you guys
Scott our parting shots anything you
want to say about the book I listen I I
don't know where it's on consider
where's it ranked on Amazon right now
are we live on Facebook how many people
are watching right now can you tell I'm
looking at this right now I'm gonna have
a little fun for myself well you're
looking that up scott party well i'm
looking at this with some parting
thoughts on the book i think this one of
the things i tried to not shy away from
was conflicting advice that I got from
different people that I interviewed for
this book it was wild how I would go to
different people who had started
different things in different industries
asking about their middles and things
that they learned and best practices and
blah blah blah blah and I would find
things that were the opposite of each
other and the question was do I pick one
side and because I want to be consistent
oh do I allow the reader to kind of
manage the conflict and mine it for
their own intuition of it obviously I
aspired for the latter and and you know
and that's the framework of the book and
in fact I put up the opposing
perspectives right next to each other
because I actually believe that that's
how people become great adventurers in
the middle right is they sort of are
able to reconcile conflicting advice
they're able to reconcile you know some
because that's the reality of the game
that is by the way if someone tells you
there's a best practice that's BS
because anything that works at one stage
of the play is the exact opposite you
want to do somewhere else about being in
love the fact that I'm a contradiction
it's my strength it is called different
things and decide in the context of the
moment which one of my swords I want so
and then we can have advice you know and
that's the thing that's it's a not a
traditional business book and I have to
tell you when I sent the manuscript in
to my publisher
right now but they came back to me like
you know the format of this it's like
insights we want to a consistent one
traditional narrative and bubble [ __ ]
yourself I was like you know this is not
the modern ways that people want to
learn you can say I was a little nicer
than I'm so proud I'm so proud of this
book like I'm excited to get it out
there I'm sorry for people to agree and
disagree and and and just you know hope
it helps hope it helps people 3704 that
is the current rank I expect the
vaynernation will go by 3 to 7 to 11
copies and give it to everybody so that
goes up number 2 he's Scott Belsky be
out be Els ky on Twitter like at Scott
Belsky every person cuz I know this is
gonna go out every human that buys this
book cuz of this podcast I want you to
tweet at Scott Belsky and tell him the
power of Gary a hundred percent
unbelievable I want you I want this to
continue to count on your feed thanks
for being a shell setting question of
the day yeah every guest I have gets to
ask the question of the day which is a
lot of fun because on YouTube and
Facebook and on Twitter and other places
you get thousands of answers which can
give us some insights what thing and by
the way it doesn't even have to be about
the book
what burning question what would you
love to get thousands of peoples of
insights on right now out of more
curiosity could be as silly as like
favorite color or favorite TV show could
be very specific to the book or
something else randomly that's
scratching your brain right now yeah I
mean gosh I mean one of the questions I
have lately is is around these these you
know these micro brands that are
emerging and we all I'd love these new
brands that seemed to me merchandize
just to us yes you know yeah Instagram
and other places and I I'm wondering a
lot these days around whether we love a
brand simply because it sort of
resonates with us and it looks cool and
whatever is a sock company we never
heard of them you like the design yeah
or if it's because of the community
associated with the brand in which case
that would argue against the sort of
longtail future brands sort of narrative
that there will be a brand for every
single person and actually eventually
there'll be a brand made for you and
will be marketed directly to you and
you'll just engage with it you don't
care who else is actually using it so I
guess I think that's not what humans do
I mean I don't I don't say yeah I'm yeah
that is like this is where people aren't
smart about history
it's not what humans do we are deeply
inherently in need of each other
I think it's community driven as well
100 [ __ ] percent but then you know I
guess the question then is the
differences distribution and awareness
has changed yes so there'll be options
so it will be amortized but not til what
like this is all community Scott do you
understand that when I walk on the
street and see a human being wearing a
Jets jersey that I am instantly family
with that person mm-hmm the same way
that somebody will walk and see a star
David or a cross yep and feel instant
family it means for a pair of Yeezys or
a long beard or a or you know a sleeve
of tattoos
we are deeply deeply in need of each
other yeah well then I guess that's the
question then because we're seeing more
and more random brands that are clever
and Coulier design Elementary zero right
and so that's what you're seeing where
is that gonna play out I mean there's
gonna be a million more brands or that
means we're gonna find our micro
community both yeah you'll have more
hundred what we haven't reconciled yet
is we need to collapse yeah we need a
macro economic collapse to reset what
will happen out of that reset I think is
you're gonna see certain people like the
ambition to build a brand that makes you
eighty eight thousand dollars a year and
you can be at home is gonna get high
right now everybody thinks they're gonna
build the next [ __ ] supreme more
Instagram mmm-hmm that needs to die
because they're not going to yeah at
this point when we change that when
young Alex fourteen year old Alex says
I'm gonna build a honey company cuz my
grandma had honey bees and I kind of
like it it's kind of I don't wanna say
that in school yet cuz I'm 14 and honey
bees for dude is not cool
but when he gets to one day I'm gonna
start a honey company and I'm gonna make
a hundred thirteen thousand a year after
profits and everything and I'm gonna
make honey and I'm gonna have fun yeah
and that's gonna make me happy yeah
that's when this shit's gonna get good
right now Scott the entry to the 1%
income makers in America is 440 thousand
hmm everybody in America thinks if you
don't make a million a year you haven't
even started making it right that's a
problem yeah like Chris that's called a
delta that is a problem
yeah when we get into making 113 happy
is a lot better than making 209
depressed yeah those people will start
taking advantage of the long tail yeah
they'll start being the person that
knits and makes 113 on Etsy yeah they're
the person that's gonna love Star Trek
and literally live life day trading on
eBay and Amazon buying Star Trek on eBay
for nine and selling it for 14 on Amazon
so those will emerge yeah as will Lola
Dan Harry's as will the person that
should be most worried about this is
Proctor and Craft Pepsi because all of
their info that's who it's gonna come
out that's true and they're also turning
it out without stories and I think that
I mean not you know coming kind of full
circle and dr. the message out there
also at the mercy of Walmart and
Albertsons yes what people don't
understand is they're not stupid yeah
they're stuck yes they're not stupid
they're stuck adobe agree adobe has
certain things because of its scale that
doesn't allow it to play with somebody
who's in a garage right now and does
something it has advantages the reason
you're important in my opinion from afar
to adobe is because you understand that
world thus knowing the hypocrisy
internally of certain things and if you
have control and I have no idea if you
do or not then you have the chance to
actually what big companies should never
lose to small companies yeah and they
always do because they have audacity
yeah well I mean I think that you start
to the business of the science of
business is scaling I mean the art of
business is the things that don't scale
and the question is how can you keep
making that happen
hey love you bye thank you so much yes
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]